it's a concept album and the main
question is what keeps you up at night
so it's you know you could be up at
night because you're reeling from just
having met someone and you're falling
for them or you could be plotting
Revenge you could be uh
yeah you could be thinking about the
time that they they painted your teeth
Brown
um you could be you could be thinking
about what could have been you know
there's just so many possibilities if
you give that like if you think of that
as like a creative writing prompt which
is what I did that's where the album
came from and this album couldn't have
owned again I mean amazing reviews you
broke streaming records and a lot of the
rave reviews have asked the question and
it is a question that the great
songwriting on this album is part of it
due to the fact that you've been doing
this sort of strange work of
re-recording your back catalog so it was
like you were doing homework on
songwriting I think so I really do I've
been so I've been re-recording uh my
first six albums because there was a
thing that happened where I had wanted
to own my work of my first six albums
and I when I changed record labels my
first six albums were actually sold
away from me
um and so I decided to just I just
figured if I if I made them the first
time I can make them again I love it I
love it
yes yeah but without me this is it
working like our radio stations playing
the Taylor version yes they've actually
there's actually one of the things I was
most thankful for was there's a there's
a company of many stations in America
called I heart and they have uh sworn to
only play my new versions and they've
said that they'll switch it out for the
old versions every time I put out a new
version of a song which is just like
it's so heartwarming to me because this
is something that I care about but I
don't expect other people to care about
it it's something that's very personal
to me and it's a lot of work but it's
like it's it's really fun and rewarding
for me and I can't believe people have
actually gotten behind it the way they
have
[Music]